scientists are not eliminating God the
eliminating models of God you learn
Sanskrit go back to your scriptures go
back to your Vedas and realize that God
is one division in Islam is prohibited
we understand the concept of God in
Hinduism Quran is the most positive book
every day more than 3,000 fetes are
being aborted in India after they
identified that they're females
according to the statistic of 1996 US
Department of Justice
2,713 women are being raped every day
every th one raped in us the time I'm
here Islam has the solutions to the
problems of the west of the
West it's time to give it's time to live
honestly with no
pretend it's time to share it's time to
care about every move you
make it's time to share and to declare
the Hope in my heart won't
break it will
[Music]
never I'm especially happy to see that
alhamdulillah we have in our midst an
international scholar of the repute of
Dr zaker Nike who shall be addressing
you shortly so please kindly take your
seats and be ready and prepared
inshallah for what is going to be an
amazing
[Music]
evening for
be
[Music]
m
s
I've been
interested to present the brief
translation of these few ayat these
ayats are from Surah FJ and it explains
about the shared problem of humanity
when
Allah favors a human being by making him
well off and
Rich then human beings become proud of
themselves saying I am a person of honor
and when Allah subhanahu ta'ala
puts human being through a trial of
limited
livelihood and hardship then human being
becomes very pessimist and he says that
Allah has made me live in a derogatory
situation but Kal Allah tal is saying
there is no need to be proud or need to
be put down
yourself but we should
work we all human beings Muslims and
nonm Muslims
should honor and dignify the
orphans and we should encourage each
other for charitable work to feed the
poor and should not try to eat up the
common and shared and Mal bequest wealth
in an un Islamic manner in a
illegitimate manner so the solution to
all the different differences in the
human being is to look after Yim to feed
the poor and do the charitable and good
deed in our life and by this way
inshallah we are going to make impact in
this Society where the majority of
people are non-muslims and Islam and
Muslims will earn good name
inshallah in the name of Allah the
beneficent the
merciful Dr Zakir Abdul Karim Nik sobal
sakani respected guests and
Elders brothers and sisters in
Islam asalamu
alaykum May the peace and blessings of
Allah be upon you all I am truly humbled
here today before you for the
opportunity that
subhana ta'ala has bestowed upon me to
address this distinguished Gathering and
I thank him for this may I take this
opportunity of warmly welcoming you all
to the lecture
program of Dr Zakir n organized by the
Islamic Association of North
London in cooperation with the Harrow
Central mosque
please allow me to introduce my panel to
you and also to explain the program
format for tonight
inshallah but first let me introduce
myself my name is Bashir satar and I am
chairman of the Islamic Association of
North London it is my pleasure to be
your host and program director for this
evening
inshallah to my right and from from the
far end we have Muti Abdul Kad
barkatullah who is The Honorable
Secretary of the Islamic Association of
North London and next to him we have Dr
mum zawan Khan who is vice chairman then
we have brother Shahed akal who is
Chairman of the Harrow Central mosque
and then we have sir ibal
sakrani Who is the Secretary General of
the Muslim Council of Britain also known
as MCB and sitting to his left the
eminent scholar from
Mumbai Dr Zakir Abdul Karim
[Applause]
N I would now like to explain the format
for this evening and this will be as
follows after myself I will be asking
sir
ibal to introduce this evening's guest
speaker after Dr sab's lecture there
will be a question and answer session
and I will provide the rules and the
process for conducting this part of the
program which will be a little later on
the Q&A session will be followed by a
recital of reflection of the program by
Brother Shahed akal
I would also just like to say that we at
the Islamic Association of North London
felt it was an opportunity in the
aftermath of
77 to reflect on our duties and
responsibilities and roles as Muslims in
this non-muslim society and put matters
into perspective in the Islamic context
for the benefit of both
Muslims and non-muslims
and who else better than our very own Dr
Zakir V to provide that very inspiration
inshallah as many of you are aware this
lecture has been arranged at very short
notice so please forgive our
shortcomings or
errors we hope that this lecture will
bring benefit and Enlightenment to us
all and we sincerely hope you enjoy this
evening
inshallah may I now invite sir ibal
sakrani to the
podium our distinguished scholar of this
evening Dr Zak n brother Bashir and
brother Shahed the management committee
members of the Islamic Northland
Association and the hero Central
mosque distinguished Scholars brothers
and sisters
assum it is indeed my privilege to
introduce our chief guest this evening a
person who perhaps requires no
introduction
whatsoever but however the introduction
is
needed to remind
ourselves of the wonderful work in in
terms of dawa that has been carried out
the much needed da work in today's
times that is carried out by this
personality which is beamed over around
the world
daily for sometimes 2 hours to up to 4
hours every single day by major national
television
stations and many other small channels
trying to get the message the central
message as to who we are what is the
dean of Islam and its role in the
society at large Dr N
alhamdulillah is a medical doctor by
profession but it is now more than 14
years that he
felt that he had served to treat the
body the human body but perhaps it was
now time to treat the
soul and in that aspect the work that he
has been carried out is more of a
full-time
work he has
established a renowned Research
Institute in
Bombay which employs more than 200
people with different Scholars being
trained to give lectures in different
parts of the world it is that much
needed work
that makes us feel
comfortable that in all the challenges
that we are facing not just in the
UK in the Muslim worlds but the world
over and it is such renowned
speakers that can bring that message of
understanding message of mutual
understanding respect
tolerance and to give the true image of
Islam which sadly is been confused and
manipulated
by those who do not wish to see Islam
grow and progress in this modern world
therefore with this few words I'm
delighted to introduce our respected
scholar but before he comes in may I
take the opportunity to thank the
organizers of both the institutions the
north London Islamic Association and the
hero Central mosque for organizing this
wonderful event within such a short
period of time and it shows the interest
within the Muslim Community to hear uh
from such distinguished Scholars the
message that they want to convey to us
so that we in our daily lives can try
and bring that message to show The World
At Large who we are and what are the
teachings of Islam may Allah guide us
through these difficult times that we
are moving through and we hope and pray
we'll have more such opportunities in
our daily lives to hear from from our
distinguished scholar Dr zakin neam
[Applause]
[Music]
alikum alhamdulillah
the respected people on the
Das my respected elders and my dear
brothers and sisters I welcome all of
you with the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah
of almighty God be on all of
you the topic of this evening's talk
is the role of the Muslims in a
non-muslim
society first let us understand what is
the meaning of the word Muslim Muslim
means a person who follows
Islam Islam comes from the root word
Salam which means peace it is also
derived from the Arabic word s which
means to submit your will to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to almighty God in
short Islam means peace acquired by
submitting your will to Allah subhah wa
ta'ala to almighty God and
anyone who submits his will to almighty
God and acquires peace is called as a
Muslim so in short Muslim is a person
who acquires Peace by submitting his
will to Allah subhana wa ta'ala to
almighty God as far as the role of the
Muslims in a non-muslim society is
concerned it can be divided broadly into
two
categories the first
is the
actions and deeds related to
himself and the other is the actions and
deeds related to the
non-muslim as far as the first category
is concerned that is the actions and
deeds of a Muslim related to
himself it is the same irrespective
whether that Muslim lives in a Muslim
Society or a non-muslim
society the actions and the Deeds are
the
same there are certain concessions given
in certain situations but it does not
differ whether the Muslim is living in a
Muslim Society or the non-muslim society
it is the
same for example what is
f what is compulsory for a Muslim in a
Muslim Society is also f is also
compulsory for a Muslim in a non-muslim
society for
example every
Muslim has to believe and worship only
one almighty God Allah subhana wa ta'ala
irrespective whether he living in a
Muslim Society or a non-muslim society
he should believe in toed he should
worship only one Allah subhana wa tala a
Muslim has to pray five times a day
minimum in a Muslim Society the same has
to be done by that Muslim even if he
lives in a non-muslim
society fine there may be different
situation in a Muslim Society there may
be a mosque in every area there may be a
mosque in Every Second Street which may
not be the case in a non-muslim society
but yet if a Muslim is living in a
non-muslim society he has to offer five
times Salah it is compulsory it is
f if the mosque is not closed by or you
have to travel long and he cannot do
that he has to offer Salah maybe in his
office or at home but Salah is f he has
no excuse to miss it a Muslim
irrespective whether he's living in a
Muslim or a non-muslim society he has to
give
zakat if he's entitled to give if he has
a saving of more than the nisab level
more than 85 grams of gold he or she
should give
2.5% of that excess wealth of that
saving
every lunar year in
charity a Muslim cannot say that he's
living in a non-muslim society and the
standard of living is high or the place
where he's living it is expensive
therefore he will not give zakat if he
has a saving of more than the nisab
level 85 gram of gold he or she should
give zakat every
year a Muslim irrespective whether they
living in a Muslim or a non-muslim
society he has to fast in the month of
Ramadan if the days are short in Winter
maybe the timings will be less if it's
in summer where the days are long the
timing of the fast would be longer but
he has to fast compulsory he has no
excuse if he lives in non-muslim society
he has no excuse he has to fast
similarly a
Muslim if he has the means to perform
Hajj if he's an adult he should at least
perform Hajj once in his
lifetime if he has the means health and
money he has to offer Hajj there's no
excuse even if he's living in a
non-muslim
society he may be living far away from
Saudi Arabia from
Makkah but if he has the means to travel
that distance he has to offer Hajj at
least once in his lifetime it is far in
this way all the far all all the actions
and deeds which are compulsory for a
Muslim in a Muslim Society is also
compulsory in a non-muslim
society a Muslim
woman she has to do hijab irrespective
whether she's living in a Muslim or
non-muslim Society she has no excuse
that she's living in non-muslim society
that's the reason she will not do hijab
there's no excuse a it has to be done in
this way all the other fars being
Hest speaking the truth it is the same
it does not
differ similarly what is Haram for a
Muslim in a Muslim Society is also Haram
for a Muslim in a non-muslim society
whichever part of the world he lives in
shik is
Haram he's living in a Muslim Society
it's also Haram if he's living in a
non-muslim society there's no excuse
that because he's staying in a
non-muslim society or a Western Country
he can do
shik it's Haram throughout the
world
similarly fornication and
adultery it is Haram for a Muslim
irrespective whether he's living in a
Muslim or non-muslim Society
irrespective which part of the world he
lives in poke is Haram whether he lives
in a Muslim country or non-muslim
country having non zabia food non-h
halal food any meat
which is not sorted by the Islamic
method or which Quran does not give
permission to it is Haram irrespective
whether is living in a Muslim or
non-muslim Society in short whatever is
far and whatever is Haram for a Muslim
it is the same throughout the world
irrespective whether he living in a
Muslim or a non-muslim society there are
many Muslims who give excuse that
because I'm living in a western country
or because I'm living in non-muslim
society some things are excused what is
f is f what is Haram is
Haram as far as the other aspects are
concerned regarding must things which
are
encouraged those which are considered as
Sunnah must which is encouraged it is
the same also
but there may be a little bit leniency
for example covering the head for a
Muslim man or wearing a cap is must it
is a Sunnah of the
Prophet but if you feel that are living
in a non-muslim
society and you feel that wearing a cap
May endanger your life and if you want
to avoid that act you can do it because
wearing a cap is not F in Islam if you
do it you will get plus points if you
don't do it you have no loss but
you will not get the plus
points so living in a non-muslim society
the things is must if you fear regarding
certain aspects and you avoid
it you will not get the plus points
similarly things which are
maku things which are
discouraged or the same throughout the
world but they can be little bit
leniency for
example going for the C of
nature
standing and doing the call of nature it
is
Mak but if you know living in a western
country and the toilets may not permit
you and if you do it there is no problem
but you will lose the plus points you
don't get negative points so as far as
the F and the harams are
concerned there is no excuse at all as
far as the other aspects are concerned
about the Sunnah and the makru if you
want to avoid it for certain reason you
can do it you will not get negative
points but you will lose the positive
points this was in short regarding the
first
category of a behavior of a Muslim in a
non-muslim
society as far as the second category is
concerned the
role of a Muslim in a non-muslim society
as far as relationships with a
non-muslim is concerned as far as
actions and deeds with a non-muslim is
concerned it can be further divided into
three
subcategories the first
is General dealing with the
non-muslim the second is special
relationships with the non-muslims and
the third is
dawa with the non-muslims as as far as
the first subcategory is
concerned regarding the general dealings
of a
muslim with the non-muslims it is the
same you have to be honest with the
non-muslim you have to be kind to him
you have to be just with him you have to
be
merciful as far as the general dealing
is concerned in day-to-day life which
does not directly concern
harming your IM then how you deal with a
Muslim you have to deal the same way
with a non-muslim in general day-to-day
dealings and there are many Muslims who
say ah he's a non-muslim you know so if
I cheat him it's not a
problem Islam does not give you
permission to cheat anyone whether a
Muslim or non-muslim Islam does not give
you permission to deal
unjustly with whether the Muslim or with
a non-muslim it's the
same
and this can be derived from two vers of
the Glorious Quran from
Surah chapter number 60 verse number 8
and 9 and Allah subhana tala says in the
Quran in Sur chapter number 60 verse
number 8 that Allah forbids you
not as far as those non-muslims are
concerned who fight you not for your
faith nor drive you out of your homes
from dealing with them with Justice and
kindness for Allah subhah wa ta'ala
loves those who are just and kind so
here Allah tells us that as far as the
non-muslims are concerned as long as
they do not fight you for your
faith for your IM or do not drive you
out of your
home Allah forbids you not from dealing
with them with Justice and kindness for
Allah loves those who are just and kind
but the next verse of the Quran Allah
says in Surah chapter number 60 verse
number 9 but Allah forbids you only as
far as those non-muslims are concerned
who fight to fall your
faith and drive you out of your homes or
support those people who indulge in
these activities Allah forbid BS
you from keeping friendship and asking
for protection from these people so if a
non-muslim fights you for your faith or
drives you out of your home or supports
those people who fight you for your
faith or drive you out of the homes
Allah forbids you from going to them for
friendship or for protection so here
Allah subh is very clear that under
normal circumstances with a non-muslim
you have to R justly and kindly unless
he fights for your faith or drives you
out of your
home and there's a verse in the
Quran which many of the Muslims they
misunderstand Allah says in the Quran
Ina chapter number four verse number 144
where Allah
says oh you who
believe take not for
aah the unbelievers in preference to the
believer
and many of the translations they
translate the Arabic word aah as friends
so the translation reads that oh you who
believe do not take for friends
unbelievers in preference to Believers
which I feel it's a wrong translation
the correct translation is the word AIA
should be translated as someone who's a
protector so the right translation is
that oh you who believe do not take for
protectors
unbelievers in preference to believers
do not take for protectors non-muslims
in preference to
Muslims and the same message repeated in
s MAA chapter number 5 verse number 57
and
58 that all you who
believe do not take for friends and
protectors those
who make a mockery of
religion or take it as a sport that
means all those
non-muslims who take your Dean as a
mockery or as a sport do not keep
friendship with them nor go to them for
protection these verses of the Quran are
very
clear but otherwise keeping acquaintance
ship with a
non-muslim keeping normal friendship
with a non-muslim is no problem at all
under normal
circumstances we should treat the
non-muslims with Justice and kindness in
fact I say we should go a step further
so that they're impressed with our
religion they're impressed with our Dean
and you can find several
examples in the life history of the
Prophet Muhammad Salli wasallam several
you can give a talk only on giving
examples how the prophet dealt with the
non-muslims and many of us aware
of that incident where a
non-muslim he enters the MOs of the
prophet and he rates the sahabas are
irritated they want to teach the non-
Muslim a lesson but the prophet he stops
them and he says be calm get some water
and wash the floor that's it we know of
the famous
incidents whenever Prophet M sallallah
Ali wasallam used to walk there was a
non-muslim lady who used to throw dirt
on the prophet every day whenever we
used to walk the non-muslim lady used to
throw dirt one day when the prophet
walks below the house of that non-muslim
lady no dirt falls on him so he's
surprised he goes to a house to find out
why was no dirt thrown
today and he realizes that she was sick
and he
prays for a shifa
and that non-muslim
lady she's so impressed with the prophet
that she accepts
Islam we have the example in the S of
the Prophet mm wasallam that there was a
Jew by the name of
Zed the prophet had borrowed some money
from him but before the time was due
that Jew he comes to the prophet and he
demands for the money back and he's
rude he speaks rudely to the prophet
that give my money back and and the time
was not yet
up he gets angry and he says oh enemy of
God had it not been for the treaty
between the Muslims and the Jews I would
have chopped off your head for speaking
to the prophet like
that we know that he was a man of
Justice he gets irritated how could
someone speak to the prophet of Allah
like that the prophet immediately
intervenes and he
tells that be calm and he tells
that give this
Jew his money back and add to it the
amount of 20 gallons because you
frightened
him because frightened him the man did
not have the right to ask the money
because the time wasn't yet up the time
wasn't due yet because Omar he
frightened that non-muslim the prophet
said besides giving the money back to
him add 20 gallons
worth because he had fighten the Jew
and alhamdulillah the Jew is impressed
with the behavior of the prophet and he
accepts
Islam so generally the Muslims should be
kind and just to the non-muslims we have
to be the right example so that they'll
realize we are the followers of the
religion of Peace a Muslim is a person
who acquires Peace by submitting his
will to Allah subhana wa ta'ala so as
far as General dealing is concerned we
have to be kind and just
but there is a caution which always
mentioned in my talk whenever I'm
dealing with this
topic that keeping non-muslim friends is
no problem as long as you are having an
influence on that
non-muslim if it's the wice Versa then
there is a danger if the non-muslim
friend is is having a greater influence
on you then there is a
problem because whenever there is a
relationship between two human
beings and when you keep on meeting very
often no one can tell me that nothing
happens either you're influencing him or
he's influencing you you can't say that
nothing is happening so if you're having
influence on him alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah continue the relationship
so that he understands the the of Islam
better but if he's having influence on
you then be careful you may follow his
path which may be
wrong so here if it's a
relationship in which your Dean is in
danger then I feel you have to
discontinue that relationship you have
to be careful the Quran is very clear as
far as protection is concerned if the
there are two options believer and
unbeliever a Believer is preferable at
all times the word says do not take
unbelievers for protectors in preference
to
Believers so as far as your Dean is not
in danger and if you are having an
influence on the non-muslim
alhamdulillah and I by the grace of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala I have hundreds
of non-muslim friends mallah hundreds
Hindus Christians many and
and almost all that I know they respect
me mashallah they know that I'm a d i
speak about the
religion yet
alhamdulillah they respect me so as long
as you are having influence on them it's
very good in terms of special
relationship where your Dean is in
danger I like to give an example Allah
says in the Quran in Surah Bak chapter
number two verse number
221 that the believing
man a Muslim should not marry a mush an
idolatress an unbelieving woman unless
she believes a believing woman who is a
slave woman is better than unbelieving
woman even if she allows you that means
a Muslim man cannot marry a non-muslim
woman a woman who does idol worship who
does shik unless she believes unless she
becomes a Muslim unless she becomes a
m
because a muslima a m a believing woman
is far better than unbelieving woman
even if she allows you means in
preference to marry a Muslim woman even
if she may be a slave woman she may be a
born woman she may be a very poor woman
she may be an ugly woman if she has
Faith she's far superior than an
unbelieving woman even if she allows you
she may be the most beautiful woman in
the world she may be the richest woman
in the world yet a muslima a believing
woman who's poor and ugly is far
superior than unbelieving woman and the
same
goes wife Vera that a believing woman
should not marry an unbelieving man a
mushrik man until he believes a
believing man even if he's a slave man
he's far superior
to a man who does sh even he may allow
you he may be the most handsome man in
the world he may be the richest man in
the world he may be the king of the
country but a believing man even if he's
poor even if he's ugly he's far better
in marriage
than a mushrik man so here because the
relationship is concerned that if you
marry a non-muslim if you marry a mush
or a mush your Dean is in
danger that that's the reason it is
prohibited for a Muslim to marry a
non-muslim marry a mush otherwise under
normal circumstances in general dealing
you have to be kind to the
non-muslim we come to the third
subcategory of the role of a Muslim in
non-muslim society that is dealing with
the non-muslims and that third
subcategory is
dawa what is the meaning of the Arabic
word dawa
those who come from the Indian
subcontinent they know the meaning of
the word
dawat the moment you hear the word dawat
you start thinking of a Biryani or a
Pula da Daw does not mean Biryani or P
dawa means to call to
invite and an invitation can only be
given to an outsider so dawa
specifically means in fighting a
non-muslim towards Islam when you speak
about Islam to a Muslim the more
appropriate word is islah which means to
repair which means to improve but when
we speak about Islam to a non-muslim
inviting him towards Islam the more
appropriate word is dawa though this
word dawa is used synonymously both
while speaking to Muslim as well as
non-muslims but specifically dawa means
inviting the non-muslims towards Islam
and this dawa is a f on every Muslim
especially those Muslims who are living
in a non-muslim
society I started my talk by quoting a
verse from the Glorious Quran from Surah
al- Imran chapter number three verse 110
where Allah
says oh Muslims ye are the best of
people EV all for mankind
Allah is giving us an honor and calling
us the best of
people Whenever there is honor it is
always followed up with a responsibility
there is no honor without
responsibility for
example in a school the principal has
got more honor than a
teacher a teacher has got more honor
than a
clerk but simultaneously the principal
has got more responsibility than a
teacher a teacher has got more
responsibility than a clerk there is no
honor without responsibility Allah is
giving us an honor in the Quran as
calling us
the Muslims ye are the best of people EV
all for mankind don't you think we have
a
responsibility the reply is given in the
same verse Allah continues and
says because we enjoy what is good and
we forbid what is wrong and we believe
in Allah if we do not enjoy what is good
and if we do not forbid what is wrong we
aren't fit to be called as we aren't fit
to be called as Muslims it is compulsory
for every Muslim that he
invites the non-muslims he invites them
towards the good and forbids them from
doing wrong and believe in
Allah Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Muhammad
chapter number
47 verse number 38 that if you do not do
your job if you do not follow the
responsibility Allah has given you Allah
says Allah will substitute in your place
and other
people and they will not be like you if
you do not do your job if you do not
follow the Commandments of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala Allah will substitute in your
place and other people and they will not
be like
you Allah says in the Quran in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number 143 that
we have made you an um a middl most
community so that you may be a witness
over the Nations as the prophet will be
a witness over you it's the duty of
every Muslim to convey The Message of
Islam to the
non-muslims I'd like to ask you a
question suppose course you go away from
your
home from your house for work and your
neighbor he abuses your mother he uses
foul language against your
mother when you come back home and when
you come to know that your neighbor has
used foul language against your mother
what will you
do what will you do when you get back
home and you come to know that your
neighbor has used language against your
mother for no reason at all and when you
get back home and when you come to know
about this what will you
do what will you
do what will you do beat him
up what will you
do bash him what do you
do kill
him one brother is saying beat him up
other brother is saying bash him third
person and kill
him when you get back home and you come
to know that your neighbor has abused
use foul language against your mother
for no Rhyme or Reason someone wants to
beat him up someone wants to bash him
someone wants to kill him but you'll see
to it that your neighbor is taught a
lesson will you or
not yes or no of course if you cannot do
it yourself you will hire someone else
to do the job yes or no of course
because we love our
mother we respect our
mother fine we'll see to it that we will
teach that neighbor a
lesson I want to ask you a question
that's in this world who do you love the
most number
one who do you love the
most Allah we love Allah subhana tala
more than our mother more than our
father more than our wife more than our
children we love him number one you ask
any Muslim and the reply would be the
same that the person you love the most
is
Allah Allah says in the
Quran in Surah
maram chapter number 19 verse number 88
to92 Allah
says that they
say the non-muslims the Jews and the
Christians that Allah subhah wa ta'ala
has begotten a son like the
indeed they have put forth a thing which
is most
monstrous as though the skies are ready
to
burst the Earth to split us
under and the mountains to fall down to
utter ruin Allah says in the Quran if
anyone says that Allah has begotten a
sun if the sky had feelings the sky
would have burst open if the Earth had
feelings the Earth would have split open
the mountains would have fallen down to
utter ruin if if anyone says that Allah
has begotten a son because anyone who
says that Allah has begotten a son it is
one of the most heinous things you can
say about Allah subhana wa ta'ala we see
today especially in the non-muslim
society every day our non-muslim friends
our non-muslim colleagues they are
abusing Allah subhana wa ta'ala they are
saying Allah has begotten a sun and we
can't even open our
mouth when we ask a Muslim who who you
love the most the reply is
Allah when someone wants to abuse our
mother you f language against a mother
you want to beat him up you want to bash
him you want to kill him and every day
people are abusing Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and you can't even open your
mouth I'm not telling that you go and
Bash him I'm not telling go and beat him
I'm not saying go and kill him it's not
allowed in
Islam you can't kill a non-muslim
because he's abusing Allah subhana wa
tala it's not allowed just for that at
least open your
mouth when somebody is abusing your
mother you want to beat him you want to
bash him every day our non-muslim
friends our non-muslim
colleagues they are abusing Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and we can't even open
our mouth leave aside opening our mouth
we go and become party to
them very soon after a couple couple of
weeks it going to be Christmas
season and many of us
Muslims we wish our Christian friends
Merry Christmas leave us at correcting
them you are becoming party to them you
know the Christians they celebrate
Christmas and they say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon Him is the Son of God and
God begot Jesus Christ peace be upon on
25th of December leave aside correcting
them you are congratulating them you are
giving
shahada that Allah subhana wa ta'ala
knowah has begotten a son on the 25th of
December div said correcting them you
are giving
shahada Merry Christmas Means what
you're congratulating him and giving
witness that nah Allah has begotten a
son on the 25th of
December we have to open a
mouth I'm not saying go and beat them or
B them at least open a
mouth can't you open a
mouth non-muslim Society whether it's a
Christian Society or Hindu
Society same thing there their Festival
which is very common from where I come
that is Ganesh chatti
ganpati and many Muslims go to this
festival and when they offer the
Prasad the food which is put in front of
the
idol the Muslims know it is Haram
but how can they offend their friend
he'll feel bad so what they do they say
Bismillah and have
it so tomorrow they'll say Bismillah and
I have poke day after tomorrow they say
Bismillah and I have alcohol what's
happening to the Muslim um we can't even
open our mouth who are we afraid of it
is so
easy believe me to talk is so easy only
thing you have to open a
mouth you don't have to insult him you
don't have to AB him Quran clearly says
in Surah Anam chapter number 6 verse 108
revile not those abuse not those Gods
who worship besides Allah left in the
ignorance they will abuse Allah subhana
wa ta'ala they will Reva Allah subhana
wa taala so you do not have to use fall
language against them only thing you
have to ask them simple questions it's
so
easy but we Muslims we are afraid to
open a mouth we afraid to dawa because
if I open my mouth I will lose this
friendship
we are more interested in keeping
friends with a non-muslim than the
friendship with Allah subhana wa
tala and believe me if you really speak
about H they will respect
you the experience that I have in my
life being in a Medical College I never
had problems in fact when I studied in
Bombay the percentage of Muslim was very
few 5 6% when asked to speak with the
non-muslims all my Muslims run away now
he's going to give us a bashing so they
run away but I never had a problem no
non-muslim has yet caught my
collar alhamdulillah when you speak the
truth they respect you
and when I was in Medical College it's
compulsory we have to pass in vaa war in
vaa and 50% of our marks and all the
subjects for vaa and I as to dawa even
with my
professors many people said that if you
do too much of DA they will fail you
so I said no problem Allah if he wants
that I should do dawa one more year with
them no
problem but alhamdulillah what should we
be afraid
of we should open our mouth but
unfortunately we Muslims we are afraid
we are more interested in keeping the
Friendship of our non-muslim friends
rather than friendship of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala
Allah says in the Quran inah Bak chapter
number 2 verse number 120
the Jews and the Christians they will
never be satisfied until you follow
their brand of religion until you follow
their way of
life Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Bak chapter number two verse number
111 they say the Jews and Christians you
Muslims you shall never enter Jenna
unless you become a Jew or a Christian
with all your
with all your Salah with the mark on
your forehead with the fasting you do in
the month of Ramadan with h you have
performed you shall never enter jna
unless you become a Jew or a Christian
Allah
says this is The Wishful
Thinking tell
them produce your
proof but if you're truthful Allah says
if anyone makes tall claims tell
them produce your proof
but if you're truthful and the
Christians they have produced the Bible
in no less than 2,000 different
languages they say my Bible says this my
Bible says that my Bible says this my
Bible says that what do we have to do do
we have to follow the Bible Hook Line
and
Sinker when anyone shows you his
identity card what do you do you verify
whether that card is correct or not so
when they are telling you the Bible is
the word of God what do we have to do we
have to analyze the scriptures how many
of us Muslims are analizing the
scriptures how many of
us leave aside we doing dawa to them
with their scriptures these Christian
missionaries they are using our Quran
our Quran against
us the Christian missionaries they come
knocking at a
door and they ask us a question they
come knocking at the doors of the
Muslims and they ask us the question
that isn't it mentioned in the Quran
that Bible is the word of God and most
of us will say yes then the next
question is then why don't you follow
the
Bible and we have got no
reply that's the next
question that how many times is the name
of your last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him mentioned in
the
Quran if you know you will say five
times four times as Muhammad and once as
Ahmed Sall wasallam how many times is
the name of Jesus Christ peace be upon
Him mentioned in the Quran if you don't
know they will tell you Jesus Christ
peace be upon Him by name is mentioned
25 times in the
Quran there's the next question who's
greater a person who's mentioned five
times by name in the Quran is greater or
a person who's mentioned 25 times by
name in the Quran is
greater they ask the question but they
will not give you the reply Li to let
your mind
think there the next
question the prophet Muhammad
saham did he have a father and mother we
say yes he had a father and mother did
Jesus Christ peace be upon him did he
have a father and mother we have to
agree that as for the teaching of the
Quran isaam Jesus Christ peace be upon
him had a mother but he had no father
there a ni question who's greater a
person who has a father is greater or a
person who does does not have a father
is greater a person who's
born by the help of the father is
greater or a person who's born without a
father is greater who's greater a person
who has a father's gor or a person who
does not have a father's gor who's
greater who's
greater they ask the question but they
don't give you the reply they let your
mind
think they're using us Muslims as
punching bags as D mats they're making
nest in our head and we can't even open
our mouth it's a
shame that the next
question
that did your Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam do any Miracles
we say yes he did several miracles do
you know of any miracle in which he gave
life to the dead and we have to agree
that nowhere does the Quran or any
Hadith say that Muhammad sallallah Al
wasallam give life to the dead there's
the next question did Jesus Christ peace
be upon him did he give life to the dead
and we have to agree the Quran says bah
wake up in the name of Allah yes he gave
life to the dead so who's greater a
person who can give life to the dead is
greater or a person who cannot give life
to the dead is greater who's greater a
person who can give life to the dead is
greater or a person who cannot give life
to the dead is greater who's
greater who's
greater who
the question is who's
greater when you say who's greater in
English it has to be one of the two
unless your English is
weak they ask the question but they
don't give you the reply they let your
mind think